foreign
you guys know what this is because you
don't live under a rock okay look
this by the way this original grain
let's unbox this is killing us watch
dude are you kidding me look at this oh
see they got the nice stuff here oh boy
it's heavy it's like it's like a nice
like it's a heavy hitter but it's also
like what do you call it um like for a
real man you know what I mean it's like
for a real man look at that look at that
that's cool it's got some oh yeah look
at that the favorites are still here
they sent us a brand new burl wood
silver 44 millimeter Chrono watch this
is all made of rare and rugged burl wood
do you know what that is well you should
larger face larger face right there on
the watch great blend of style and
functionality you got wedding rings or
just regular Rings if you want really
um comes with a stopwatch Timing System
here and the calendar date function the
back of the watch can be engraved with a
personalized message
what's that good for Christmas Christmas
weddings anniversaries birthdays yada
yada the list goes on even get it for
boxing day uh they're perfect to pair
with our burlwood silver tungsten ring
bam or this one here we got uh and the
sunglasses that look so ill on me back
in stock they sold out after our our
last ads and um if you use the link
uh end the code then you can get these
you can get all everything you see here
uh that's code lifeline
at originalgrain.com
Lifeline so go to originalgrain.com
Lifeline use the code Lifeline to get uh
30 off
site-wise so you get all this stuff and
then knock it down 30 percent
killer
because these watches are killing it
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
hello hello hello hello
on ecstasy
I'm rolling dude I'm rolling rolling
rolling oh I'm rolling rolling rolling
rolling The Worst remix of all time I'm
rolling the Limp Bizkit [__]
Sandstorm remix dude Sandstorm needs to
play a show when Mike Piazza would come
to bat at the old they did Stadium yeah
dude that's weird that's a weird song
for [__] Mike Piazza to be playing do
you remember how hardcore the rumors
were about him being gay yeah you do
yeah is he gay I thought he was no no
he's not gay no he's not gay oh wow and
the reason I brought it up because he
would the thing with that like even if
you have some weird stick up your ass
about like being thought of as gay it
like bothers you immensely for some
reason which it shouldn't who gives a
[__] but he made the great mistake of
getting mad once oh really or maybe more
than once yeah but I've seen it where he
would he just like turn like like Jim
Everett with [__] ah yeah yeah yeah
uh uh Chris yeah that and then [__]
the guy he was so mad and it was like oh
dude well now now we think that you yeah
going on you know what I mean oh so you
smoke poles so it's all good so you
smoke poles
um smoke poles that's so stupid dude I
think that uh he he might still be gay
but also we don't know you know does he
have a wife and kids and stuff I don't
know but he would always date Playmates
and [__] remember that that team could
be a cover-up okay yeah he uh hold a
press conference to say he wasn't
getting it was something drastic dude
yeah hi I'm Mike Piazza I'll take your
questions a little bit but I just want
you to let you know I don't smoke poles
so stupid questions over there uh these
you so you don't smoke poles
um do you back it up into other you know
men uh do not um thank you but I do not
back it up into men
um
do you remember the Bell Sebastian Bell
and Sebastian's song about that what
Piazza New York catcher are you straight
or are you gay oh my God yeah dude leave
him alone I'll tell you what man I might
be straight okay you have no idea uh I
mean I actually do know but you don't
know you're not gonna say because either
way I could be I don't you know you
could be that could be gay you could be
but you're not so I'll hold a press
conference later about it nice guys just
so you know I'm not telling any
questions everyone should hold a press
conference on their uh preference uh
sexual preference question yes Tim do
you uh back it up into guys or do you
have girls back it up into you nice no
more questions at this time moonwalk out
of there like this
this you know yeah casting a spell
[Laughter]
dude Michael Jackson do that
look what I'm gonna do I know what
you're gonna do dude I know because it
helps I think helps what helps my my
anxiety My overall demeanor I
this is what we do we put a thing like
this poisoning himself under the tongue
cyanide all good his last shot
[Laughter]
uh you leave it under the tongue for 30
seconds uh-huh and a new chill 30
seconds well that's a long time but you
don't have to Pure Spectrum CBD we got
10 off if you're a CBD dude go under the
thing it's in the show description click
on the link and type in Lifeline code
life code like the code is Lifeline
don't type in code Lifeline the code is
Lifeline made it very confusing if you
do CBD needs and they got gummies my
baby you'll just type in Lifeline you
know what I mean dude um wow just making
a [__] mess of the set dude so now
I'm just chill I'm like [__] uh
Nicolas Cage walking around in [__]
in that movie punching me in the face
where he goes like this and when he does
what he does
um we got Lifeline live coming up
October 9th what's that that's your
birthday show it's 19th not ninth
because that's not your birthday yeah
October 19th talking over me October
19th 6 p.m Pacific time uh it's a live
show we're gonna take your calls and
we're gonna get in depth with you it's
gonna be a little longer than normal and
we got some surprises coming for that
ass so uh watch lifeline.com go there to
get tickets get them while they're hot
dude this the surprises are gonna be
very surprisy and it will be great the
worst [__]
teaser of all time all right you know
what else would be great or is great my
private sessions my private advice okay
mattelia.com get your [__] Tuesday and
Thursday 1 30 to 5 30 p.m Pacific time
uh I've been helping a lot of you out
and honestly it helps me out so it's a
nice you do it for yourself it's a good
simpatico bing bang bang boom bing bang
bang bang so
um all right so yeah and I got my tour
dates coming up chrisley.com Peoria
Rockford Raleigh Savannah Denver Peoria
Rockford Raleigh Savannah Denver and uh
Tempe oh I'm gonna do a little some Club
dates there uh all right cool what's up
guys dude you know what I'm chilling
traffic was so bad
it's always bad it's not always bad
actually sometimes here dude leave
earlier dude but I'm chill right I guess
you shouldn't be you should thank God I
did the CB I should have done that
before more worried about [__] being
on time actually I'm always late too
you're always late but I'm normally
always on time here I really am
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm more
often late than you are but you're when
you're late you're way later now that is
true yeah when I'm late that [__] makes
up for all the times I was early because
I'm like [__] 30 minutes late why is
that
um traffic
okay but not my fault wow defensive it
is not my fault dude it's always your
fault if you're late you can never blame
it on something else even if it really
was some out external circumstance last
night I saw a movie called clown
clown yeah and I was up late watching it
just clown it's called clown
and it's about a guy who his son's
birthday is happening and the clown
cancels oh I know this [__] yeah and the
dad is like he's a realtor and he's in
one of his properties and he finds a
clown outfit he's like I'm gonna I'll
save the day he goes puts a clown outfit
goes to son's thing and says hey I'm
Dumbo the clown and he's the clown now
the dad of the kid and then he can't
take the clown outfit off yeah that's
sick it is yeah and he becomes a demon
you know they made that movie in a
reverse engineered way no what's that
they made a fake trailer for it and then
Eli Roth saw it what and was like I want
to make that movie for real and he
produced it for the guys that made the
fake what yeah I knewers have big names
to it like Eli Roth and [__] yeah that's
why that's crazy dude that's why yeah
that is funny but it's crazy it's
actually funny and it it's not like by
any means like a fantastic movie but
it's like for way good for what it is
I'm like this [__] is no business being
this good and also I had to turn it off
in the middle because something like a
[__] they a kid dies and I'm just
like I'm out oh I can't watch it I can't
watch that [__] anymore oh yeah I get it
but uh how about the clown movie
speaking of clown movies the clown movie
that oh dude Anthony was trying to
Anthony's trying to pass
he started talking about this movie he
says how good it is how amazing it is it
only got made for 35 000 it's called
terrifier I put it on and
I mean the [__] hate it dude it's
like the guy the guy is creepy I'll give
him that you know but like they're
trying to find this new iconic horror
villain you know it's just a clown it's
just a clown with [__] a black you
know mouth and it's a mime it is
his name is Art the clown right that's
true it should be art the mine so why is
the [__] movie not called Art the
mind terrifiers it's not a good word a
[__] half of it and I go like this
all right I'm out dude you watch all
half yeah bro I I'm I go in I was like
12 12 minute in and out this is trash
thanks for nothing Anthony
uh anyway and I'm also in [__] and
then I had to clear I watched the clown
movie not not the terrifier watch clown
and then the kid died in it and I was
like I gotta stop I gotta clear it and I
watch [__] fast and the furious four
so I cleared it you got [__] taste yeah
so uh all right dude let's get into it
uh light let's get into Lifeline in the
news we changed it it was Lifeline
worldwide I liked it that way got vetoed
now it's called Lifeline in the news
let's face it we didn't change it we
were basically like strong armed we got
stalined into changing it because our
producer was just like it's this now
yeah so he goes like it's this now and
we go okay yeah we didn't have a choice
so here we go you want to do it okay in
August the FBI conducted a raid at
Donald Trump's Mar-A-Lago residence in
Florida claiming he'd taken thousands of
sensitive documents illegally after
leaving the White House including
nuclear-related information and
sensitive information about CIA NSA
activity Trump said he had a right to
take these he's also said he can
declassify anything he wants at any time
even simply by thinking about it
who's correct that's not for us to know
the advice
I I you know I want to say just don't
take documents outside of the White
House pretty much the documents inside
the White House should stay in the white
house right especially if they could
cause the world to explode okay so my
advice is no matter who you are don't
take documents outside of the White
House why would you do it first of all
but second of all I will say if you're
gonna do it and get caught for it
definitely act the way Trump is acting
because it's [__] hilarious well what
I don't get is he said it was a perfect
thing to do just like he said about his
Ukrainian foreign but what I don't get
is this guy will just do something
illegal yeah and then say no it's not
illegal yeah that's the craziest thing
which is kind like like he could he I
mean this guy is like he's like a few
steps away from putting on a mask
robbing a bank taking the money leaving
and when the news is like he robbed the
bank he holds a press conference and
being like it's not illegal for me to
rob the bank
as the former president yeah yeah yeah
and then people will be like oh well we
got to do something we gotta let this
play out yeah and you're like and it's
like what he's standing with the bags
with dollar signs on it doing the press
conference yeah yeah yeah so I would say
don't remove documents from the [__]
house
say I can do that okay he said he can
make anything Declassified just by
thinking about it which is maybe my
favorite thing he's ever said but that's
classified he goes like this hold on a
second not anymore you like this yeah
yeah oh really it's like what's I'm
sorry what's it classified what is it
okay hold on one second
it's not it's not anymore
all right yeah that's a good idea yeah
how about that I mean he's kind of the
way he's doing it is dude if that's true
do more [__] you could just have to
think about yeah declassify but even
expand it Beyond declassifying like do
everything you want by just thinking
about it that's great great it's a great
skill to have I wish I had it yep me too
a video oh boy a video of Chet Hanks has
gone viral of him giving a profanity
laced speech at a quote recovery Day
event in Winnipeg Canada Chet has become
a motivational influencer as of late on
social media I guess you could call him
that inspiring people to take control of
their lives through sobriety and fitness
um so I I think do you see it no did you
I saw it yeah okay he's being so like
confrontational I know and and and like
everybody's like we're just walking away
there's like a tiny crowd of people yeah
and then he just slowly like everybody
just trickles away he's being so
aggressive and being like oh what's that
you want me to hold back you oh no I say
what I say I do what I do and you're
just like it was just like [__]
lambasted by this guy like so what they
didn't sign up for he was on the king
and the sting in the wing oh yeah and uh
he was talking about vaccines and then
he got very like this and now I have to
tell you I like Chet Hanks he's a buddy
of mine
um and I think I happen to think that
this guy is an actual motivational
speaker I think that he can get people
to do things because he is okay he's
very aggro but he is not he is he he
speaks very well you know and you know I
think sometimes he lets his emotions get
the best of him what do you think but
this guy is filling a hole that somebody
is going to fill and and it's him and is
he almost I don't feel like stupid for
asking this but I'm assuming he's an
anti-vaxx or what yeah he is yes
he was like I'm not taking the fact no
matter what and he goes oh I'm thinking
this thing yeah and so I was just and I
was sitting next to him like this wow I
wonder why he got so heated about it and
it's hilarious he's doing this at
Winnipeg because I played there a bunch
of times and I mean it's just like the
most chill Place Winnipeg is like so
chill yeah it's like The Stereotype of
Canada
nice yeah okay here we go talking to you
guys
is through the grace of God
yeah okay take your kids watch your
[__] mouth
come on up here buddy oh God I don't
think you can
that's it just being like what do you
say
why are you challenging people to fight
your motivational speaker
that is just uh well that's enough we
don't need to see all of it but I mean
like we got the idea I got the idea
because there's only [__] eight
people exactly dude what was the what
was the event him it was some religious
event okay I know he's very religious
and I think that that's great if you
find something that you like like that
okay why is he [__] cursing up and
down and challenging people to fight
just because they tell them to watch his
mouth I think it's okay
that's not good I think that there's a
character that he's playing I also think
that being the motivational influencer
that is [__] laced with swear words
is [__] awesome I think I think that
that's awesome okay but there should be
that guy and I want Tony Robbins to be
like you know what I mean it's not him
though Chet is bad at it no I don't know
he's got a following dude but it's you
know why though no I don't know man not
not anymore you think if he wasn't Tom
hanks's son people would still be like
oh I love this guy yeah I think so the
white boy summer [__] video is
hilarious and like the I don't know I
mean he's a character but it's baked
into his whole identity the fact that
he's Tom Hanks is [__] yeah for a lot
of people but I don't know he stands
alone man that guy's [__] funny as
[__] anyway he's blow the [__] up so I
guess if the advice for Chet is just
[__] keep doing that [__] like that
because he's obviously helping out
whatever he's doing keep making
headlines bro yeah exactly yeah all
right next one here we go
Brazil played to Tunisia in a friendly
match in Paris on Tuesday ahead of the
World Cup
what's this [__] got what what some
guy scored Brazil's second goal for
Charleston yeah a guy who was somebody
made up yeah scored Brazil's second goal
of the game and started celebrating as
he celebrated by the corner flag a
banana was thrown onto the pitch which
was seen as a oh as a racist gesture the
Brazil fa I have said they will continue
to fight against quote racism and
Prejudice but Richardson wow uh it's
like four different names put out yeah
yeah says essentially this is empty
posturing uh stop throwing bananas but
but
wait is he black no he must be yeah
because it's racist but dude what if
you're pissed off and you're holding a
banana you literally are pissed off you
got to be like oh wait I [__] does
anybody have any other fruit
issue but I just realized why would you
have a banana at a soccer match if you
weren't planning on it's hilarious if
they're [__] like if it's a setup but
they're like get your bananas here only
bananas do you have any apples all we've
got is bananas do you have caramel
[__] popcorn only bananas but look at
what we're trying to a tight score look
somebody's [__] up here there's two
bananas they go like somebody is [__]
up ah [__] you richarlison richarlison
says as long as they say blah blah blah
and don't punish it's going to continue
like this happening every day and
everywhere they definitely okay my take
is they definitely brought bananas and
it's obviously if you're gonna do that
and throw them at a black player that
has to be a racist if you brought the
bananas
the intent has to be there yeah it has
to but that they can't bring the bananas
yes if they sell bananas it's not ready
yeah if it's like dozens of people with
[__] bananas that are ready to throw
them at him when he does something good
or bad or is close that's racist there's
no question about it I say get a banana
detector like they have gun detectives
and scan everybody when they come in
they're gonna walk in with a [__]
wait get that guy it's a banana he's got
a [__] white hood on and [__]
yeah I actually I think that has
detector uh and get a banana detector
all right cool that's good get a banana
detector and this way you don't have to
[__] be afterwards like oh do we say
something do we not do we punish do we
not just bring a [__] don't be no
banana no bananas and no guns No Bananas
No Bananas allowed yeah okay cool
what's up Matt what's up Chris loving
the show so my wife is a high school
cheerleading coach and normally we'll go
to the games on Friday nights support
the kids have a good time but we are
trying to have a kid right now and if we
had a son it came up in discussion the
other day that she does not want him to
play football due to potential for a
spinal cord uh head trauma stuff like
that and I said okay that's fine well
I'm not gonna ever go into any of your
team's games again because I don't want
to support other kids playing football
if my son's not going to be able to play
football when he's older it just feels
hypocritical yeah you have a problem
with the sport then you should have a
problem with the sport for anyone not
just your son am I being
cynic about it or do I have a good point
let me know I mean honestly that is a
fair point but also that's her job so
you you know she's making literally
you're eating because of that but dude I
think that's such a good point it is a
good point I think that that point wins
really it's so good because she's making
her money off of the the the uh
for the sport off of football itself and
if she's saying no you can't play it
it's too dangerous to her son
what that would be so weird if the dad
went and was like attending a thing
excitedly
for the school that they're not allowing
him to compete in with rather yeah that
is a good point but also
um
well what you I mean she needs a job
right unless this guy's [__] up he's
not asking her to get to quit he's
saying I shouldn't go to the game I
agree with him I think he's you know
what he found honestly a loophole he
doesn't want to but it's a good one yeah
he's like I'm so tired of [__] this
is all about he could have set this is
all by Design This is like he's the evil
villain at the end of the episode this
is it was like oh he was like this was
my plan all along yeah I didn't want to
go to your stupid games
but also I impregnated you with a boy
and you won't let him play football and
now I don't have to go yeah he was a
good successful plan this is the cherry
on top right now oh yeah dude well the
cherry on top was probably on on top is
probably you know splurting but no it's
us agreeing with him that is the cherry
on top oh well why because we hold
weight because we're so important in
their lives you think us agreeing with
them is better than him splurting
yeah he's experts many times how many
times does he get us to agree with him
okay once for sure right now that's so
you think his point wins uh also she's
not in the chair she's not doing
anything she was the coach and they're
doing her dances like I'm sorry that's
not that important that he attends that
just just watch yeah he's getting out of
some cool [__] this is awesome dude good
for him dude wow you found a loophole
it's a dick I don't know if it's a dick
only you know that you know what I mean
you know your heart and what you want I
don't even think it's a dick if she's in
the cheer group that's one thing but
obviously she's not okay all right
let's do the next one
okay hey guys I'm gonna try and make
this fast
um I'm 21 I'm a child of divorced
parents right now I live with my mom I
used to live across the country
literally never saw either of my parents
um and now I'm back home okay so
both of my parents get passive
aggressive uh when I do something with
the other parent and my mom refuses to
be in the same room as my dad my dad
doesn't really give a [__]
um but like he gets mad when he doesn't
see me for a few days like upset and my
mom gets passive aggressive when I'm
with my dad and you know I'm not home
when she's home whenever but I feel like
it's only fair to go out with my dad
more often
um and kind of go to events and things
because I live with my mom I see her
every day
um and it just feels like someone's
always upset with me and I can't be in
two places at once and I just don't
really know what the solution is because
I'm an adult and they're adults and no
one's acting like a mature adult in this
situation so I just don't know what to
do it's it's I mean it seems like she's
uh acting like the adult here she is and
also uh this is why you should have
twins huh dude they're being so [__]
childish yeah they are and well it seems
like the dad doesn't really care right
no he does he does okay but you gotta
talk to them both independently or
together and be like I'm 21. I don't owe
you guys seeing one of you every [__]
three or four days this is maniacal yeah
I'm like not it's not even like she
turned 18 she don't touch [__] 21.
right right right like let her live be
you know what I'm saying let her live be
you're saying be Cuban about it yeah let
me live B yeah
um I I uh I think honestly your parents
should call in because they need advice
they're the ones
yeah you know and it's like that's uh
that's on them somehow they produced a
totally sane daughter even though
they're clearly not of sound mind yeah
and and why don't you be like yo if if
[__] gets crazy in the conversation be
like yo you're the [__] guys who
couldn't stand each other right the
[__] guys who got divorced yeah I
like both of you don't make it even
figure it out don't make it even harder
for me by the way yeah [__] making me
feel bad I hang out with both of you I
like both of you how about that this is
all your anxiety it's really hard to
deal with though it sucks man because
you love them I get it and they love you
and it's all like [__] you don't want
to make them feel bad but I get you're
not you don't own their anxiety about it
I know it's hard because I would feel
the same way but it's very hard to not
own that because they are your loved
ones but man you just gotta be like I'm
gonna [__] hang out with both of you
chill and if you don't like it then
that's you
um that sucks that you feel that way but
I love you both and you know I mean what
else can you do let her live bees let
her let me be yeah but there's two of
them so it's let her live bees
bees let me live bees let me live beat
let me live B yeah let me live let her
live bees this is to the parents out
there of this woman
trying her best to be happy and let make
you guys happy too let her live bees
okay okay okay so proper so proper and
so Cuban um yeah yeah that sucks okay
next one
when he said that I just gotta sit him
down ask him why he thinks body code
works and hear him out even though we're
not going to get anywhere and I'm never
gonna believe that he can magically heal
people like at least he's gonna feel
like he's been heard and Chris you had
me laughing out loud when you said that
if he just realizes that he's in turmoil
he could body code himself out of it and
then he'd be good but I just got to give
you more information and he's never been
in turmoil and I don't think there's any
deep-seated like mental issue that's
causing this I think he's just really
really gullible and he's always bought
into like the latest fad Trend whether
it's like Atkins diet or like the secret
or body code or like whatever he just
buys into it fully and the one dollar
one dollar one dollar you do that enough
times and you're rich that was hilarious
but it was also way too accurate and he
charges a hundred dollars for his
service
and he claims he's gonna make a hundred
thousand dollars off it this year whoa
so there's enough dumb people out there
who are willing to give him their money
and I think that's really where the
problem is yeah yeah like when you get
money for this it makes it seem like
what you're doing works so also you're
getting money wow that's a tough one I
don't really know I gotta talk to one of
these people who's giving them their
money and see what the hell they think
is actually working but I asked him to
heal my knee and then it didn't work
last time so I have fashioned him this
wand
and Matt thank you so much for helping
me realize that there's entertainment in
this like Chris you said it sad makes
you sad that there's people out there
I'm gonna run with the entertainment
value and no choice next time he tries
to heal me I hope it works if it doesn't
I'm gonna make him like a Wizarding
staff
get him a beer and there is comedy in
this so thank you so much for helping me
realize that thank you so uh yeah uh I
mean okay so this guy thought he could
heal himself his dad thought I could
heal himself this guy seems like he's in
great spirits by the way this guy uh and
he says his dad is just gullible and
there's no turmoil okay fine I guess I
might still push back sometimes you
don't know you're in turmoil but also
you don't know what happened to him
before you were born yeah exactly
um
but I think that dude you gotta just
basically uh
uh yeah I mean you have a good attitude
about it and also the guy's making money
so that's the thing that is it that it
is dude there's enough people in the
world that you can do [__] like that
incentivizes you to convince yourself
that you believe it too when you start
seeing that [__] green that [__]
yaper that's [__] Pimpin pimp and
skrilla shut up is [__] like dude
that gouda is it'll change your mind
it'll bend your mind to accommodate [__]
that one would normally never believe
now that he's [__] got that [__]
uh chatter cheddar on his [__]
fingertips okay right yeah it's just now
that he's got the blue cheese up in
there yeah that green cheese okay you
know yeah disgusting
um uh the Gorgonzola the [__]
parmesan provolone all right a butcher
you know a menu a menu
um yeah dude I mean [__] on
a body code thing bothers you that much
uh and he's a guy who was uh you know
always with the latest fad just [__]
try to throw other fads to it I was just
gonna say give you another ones if it'll
happen she'll be like yo you ever try
[__] Jujitsu you ever try uh yoga or
you know you ever try here ride this
razor scooter for a little bit yeah you
know maybe he'll get really into
rollerblading or something yeah yeah
right right now it's body code and if
it's body code now maybe you don't have
to wait so long I mean if he's making
money he's making money but try to offer
him other things he could do that are
fad ish like mukbang [__] like just give
them a bunch of food and film it and
then put it on YouTube and then you
could be the body code guy doing mukbang
videos those kill man yeah when I put it
on my channel they get a lot of views
um I'm sorry my bang is like it's
basically you eat food and review it
kinda you know oh wow okay yeah and I
did it with like in and out and uh
Chick-fil-A and [__] okay
um and you know I go dummy viral and
it's fine but like you know if you're
the body code guy and you're going to go
dummy viral doing body code change it to
mukbang right you're not hurting anybody
and you can still make money off views
from YouTube you're not going to make
maybe you won't make a hundred thousand
dollars but maybe you will but yeah a
hundred dollars a session that's
hey your knees healed 100 bucks what is
it the thing that does again like how
does it what does he do
I forget what he does yeah but he does
something like he just says a word three
times and is like you're better now no
you said that no but I thought that was
a thing he says the Mantra three times
and you were the one who said the one
dollar one dollar one dollar that I
think I said that because
but I think that uh yeah your dad's
cuckoo like let's not let's not mince
words here yeah
that's cuckoo and I argue so gosh you're
cuckoo too he's got a little bit of
cuckoo I think this guy's cuckoo I do I
do he's obviously from like [__] you
know the outskirts of San Diego or some
[__] that doesn't matter because of the
craziest people I've ever met my life
bro really yeah dude yeah why what's up
because it's so chill and it's so chill
and you're near a city where you should
be doing something but you're not really
doing something because it's too chill
so nobody's doing anything so nobody's
really doing anything but they think
they are and then they just get [__]
crazy they start doing [__] like body
code I'm telling you dude you move
sometimes two two things some when
things are too good you come up with
[__] like body code and when things are
absolutely [__] horrible you come up
with things like bodyguard right no
normal [__] yeah unless there's
some kind of chemical imbalance in their
brain came up with something like body
code you need balance and he needs
balance in his life yeah you know yeah
maybe you're not visiting him enough so
he's like you know what [__] it my son
won't see me he's obviously a rounded
plan I know but I'm saying also make him
the wand also give him a [__] pointy
wizard hat yeah every time you see him
whenever he does it to you be like you
know as a matter of fact there's crazy
we gotta do this I got you this robe
yeah yeah and here you go give him a
little [__] um you know a beard that
hooks around the ears and be like I'm
not doing this unless you are [__]
dressed like a wizard play the role
here's Dobby by the way I have a Dobby
Adobe uh uh [__] is uh stuffed animal
for you Dobby is that [__] dude that
visits Harry Potter when he's home in
Britain and he's like everybody has some
nurse for your you watched Harry
Potter's I had to dude Kristen loves it
tastes not good there's seven of them
the only one that's kind of good is the
last one and it's only the last half of
it because it's over
this is kind of actually good whoa
really first one is just it's terrible
so it takes 15 hours to get kind of good
and then it ends
okay all right cool let's do the next
one
chilling hey dudes Chris and Matt how
you doing it's your boy Carol I was born
in Poland I live in London UK uh turned
33 the other day and I got married this
Summer and I had my own place so life
rips
um but I feel like I'm in between a few
ideas and paths and passions in my life
and in between two countries Poland and
the UK
um so I studied music production I play
in some heavy metal bands uh but I also
train golf I want to become a golf
instructor and I have a few other
passions and hobbies but in the meantime
I'm stuck in a sales job that's
completely unrelated to anything but
pays the money so it allows me to to
live my life uh so the question is how
do you figure it out when did you want
where did you figure it out that you
want to be a comedian and not a musical
theater a singer or something uh when is
a good time to figure it out as well and
how uh come to London UK and play some
shows we need you here
see you later I mean what a weird accent
he's got a little bit of English in
there but he's also got polish uh
miloshkump this guy no [__] dude
Alexander Gump
um that's uh that's crazy that he's got
so many things going on and also I don't
know he's 33 uh you know you know people
ask this question a lot and it's like
it's
it's like asking how to be good at
something like you gotta [__] just
figure that [__] out like what you're
how do I figure out what my passion is I
don't [__] know what is your passion
like you can't reverse engineer that I
think good advice when you don't have a
passion I think really good advice is
find something find out something that
you are really good at Naturally become
the best at that and whatever that is
you will make a lot of money thank you
then you will therefore have a lot of
money to do whatever the [__] you want
you won't have to worry about your
passion you will become passionate about
that thing because you will be making
that Yap or Yap or blue cheese good or
green cheese okay uh I think imagine if
[__] Tony Robbins said that but
that's the [__] truth though dude and
then imagine you made that yaper blue
cheese
um with his big ass face so uh wait do
you do does that sinking in because
that's true [__] dude British is that
sinking because that's true [__] yeah I
I I I it does sink and I you know and I
do get it it does sink in nice but first
of all this guy let's just take this guy
at face value dude you are uh uh into
heavy metal and golf
do you know what I'm saying like at
least narrow it better right the guy's
just like [__] straight up like I eat
my unborn I eat my unborn and then on
another day he's just like you know oh
wow look at that are you gonna do it
from there okay well I don't know if
I'll make it from the grill here we go
four like that's insane to different
people maybe so narrow it a little bit
at least have it be heavy metal and like
you know bowling maybe he needs to
combine the two
some kind of heavy metal thing about
golf because that would that nobody's
ever done that before
I eat my um
my unborn you know I don't know what do
they [__] say it's the worst [__]
imaginable you know what I mean they
love that movie clown for sure Slipknot
or [__] Mudvayne oh Boston oh
the [__] bands that don't show their
face that's the creepiest [__] ever also
isn't it so hot I know it's so hot it
has there's no [__] way apparently I
was listening to reading something about
the guys and stuff not like they vomit
in their own mask and never clean it
just like the most because they need to
be more slip knotty you know what I mean
like it's like the most metal [__] ever
to be like
and then just be like
and then they're just like oh I get it I
get it so far but then they're just like
no no I know
do you know what I mean yeah I do but
that's so disgusting you don't have to
be that gross it's already weird and
you're already successful and also what
I want to know is like if you're slip
knot or Mud Vein or [__] some [__]
like that like how do you get like the
perks of being a rock star like like how
do you get women how do you like do they
want to sleep with you with the mask on
probably right or because when you take
it off you just you just look like a
[__] bank teller does anybody even
know what they look like well no there's
some bands don't I mean maybe they do
they've been around for a long time I
feel like their whole
for sure right oh really what I'm saying
but like there are bands like I don't
know if Mudvayne has or whatever but
there are bands that never reveal their
face ever I mean slipknot's been around
for too long we obviously they've
revealed it but my point is if you're
looking even on the Google Images it's
the [__] the guy's got the clown [__]
on Sean crahan and he's got the [__]
you know oh my God take it off for the
Google Images thing setting this guy
yeah oh there he is right there he is
but but I want to know is so regular but
what I want to yeah exactly like you
just like if the girls are like oh my
God yeah come on let me back up into it
and the guy's like okay cool and she's
like take off the mess he takes it off
and he just looks like just a guy that
would be at a park somewhere the postman
he's like ew never mind look at that
[__] mask [__] guy yeah what oh god
[__] disturbing [__] that's very
disturbing [__] guy okay well does he
have sex with those women
he does
dude whenever whenever you're a [__]
rock star you this is just absolute
proof that you can be the ugliest man
under the [__] Sun
and you'll still get is that guy ugly
um I mean he's [__] whatever looking
no I mean with the [__] on the [__] on
yeah it's crazy yeah you just look at a
regular guy without it yeah yeah regular
he looks kind of all right he's probably
sexy dude it is just wild that they do
this this is really unsettling to me you
know yeah one time you took a screenshot
of a YouTube thing and you said it to me
I was talking and then and
there was a there was a video of about
Slipknot that was like 30 minutes and
you had watched half of it yeah what's
up with you and Slipknot I like it's
intriguing to me but what about it the
mask thing who are they and also they're
very creepy and why do they make that
music that I legitimately just don't
feel you know I know I'm saying so
that's the thing if I don't get
something at all I really want to get
into the depths of yeah I get that what
it is and I want to try and learn how to
like it sure right you know cousin
Nicholas yeah [__] loves
this [__] the guys I Lay Dying and As I
Lay Dying I'd be dying dying at death's
door they're all dying cut me open and
watch me die yeah bringing the noise
bring into dying yeah
um yeah yeah he just loves it dude and
it's creepy why does he like it I guess
that's
we obviously Anthony loves Slipknot our
brother producer dude you love Slipknot
because you could just see him he'd be
like they're gonna like slip knot for
sure it's probably part of slip knot we
have no [__] idea no he's in there
fan club no questions he's gonna get the
Discord yo yeah definitely see his real
face that's him he runs the Discord yeah
yeah yeah
um he's he runs a Discord it's called
slip
yes Slipknot the guy that wasn't a good
joke the guy who sent in and died in the
middle of a question yeah yeah yeah okay
dude that's so unsettling all right
let's go to the next one uh yeah but
first of all my my advice is narrow the
[__] wants you like golf and or
combine them which was Matt says which
is very cool be the guy who does the
[__] um what do you call it the
the the you can't be a golfer that does
metal but you can be a a metal singer
that does that does like a golf right
yeah a golfing metal singer but before I
move on real quick because I get a lot
of these questions in general tiger
death woods dude
you [__] if you don't have a passion
you can't just figure out what it is you
can't reverse engineer that [__] just
find the thing that you're the best at
become even better at it become a master
at that thing and then get [__] Rich
doing it and then it'll open up you to
have time to figure out what your
passion is and you'll be [__] wealthy
and you won't have to worry about that
[__] because that's always what stops
people who have passions from being able
to seek out and become that and do that
for a living you don't have the money to
be able to do that so in the meantime
figure out what you're [__] good at
and do that Phil death Olson what that's
what you call your band because he's a
successful golfer John Ramstein
oh right yeah yeah yeah that's what you
call your [__] John ronstein that's
great yeah yeah that's great dude
no I didn't look up golfers I know
golfers oh I don't think you do there's
no Tiger Woods and then Jack Nicholas
Jack Nicholas I know okay is that how
you pronounce it no Jack Nicholas that's
what I said you said Jack Nicholas oh
Jack Nicholas I said no there's no
there's no
so my problem is with my parents I love
them so much don't get me wrong but um I
killed them sometimes I go to them for
advice or a solution to a problem and
they will offer up whatever words of
wisdom that they have on the subject and
then time will pass and I'll deal with
the problem or the situation that I'm in
and I'll come back to them and I'll be
like hey remember this problem that I
was talking to you about this is how I
solved it
um but sometimes I won't take the route
or the solution that they gave me I'll
just kind of do it on my own so when I
go back and tell them about it they'll
get mad that I didn't do things the way
that they advised me to
and then they'll be like oh well why did
you come to me in the first place like
I'm not I was just not going to give you
advice again and I'm like wow I come to
you for advice because I I value what
you have to say but how do I tell them
that I don't have to take your advice
and I don't want you to get mad or upset
with me because I'm gonna keep coming to
you for advice
you woman oh okay I see where you're
going with this okay that's the number
one woman move dude what is what asking
for advice
it's a deeper but true I'm gonna have to
disagree I know many men that do that
and it is so shitty no yes I know many
men do that but
okay so even men who do it are women
because they do that those men should
look very closely under their nut sack
but you might have an opening but wait
wait why if that's true if both men and
women do it why is it specifically a
woman thing
women generally do it some men do it and
those men should very carefully look
under their nuts and see if there's an
opening I'm asking you what about it
makes it a woman thing what do you think
the split is like what oh
they want to talk about their problems
and women are generally people more than
men that want to talk about their
problems so really all they're doing is
venting I mean how many times have you
talked to a woman and they're like
saying [__] and they're like maybe this
or maybe that and they're just like no
and then they get frustrated and you're
like oh you just want to vent yeah right
yeah that's probably what you're doing
dude anyway that's my [__] two cents
I think that's so stupid this part
I I honestly think that that's weird
that your parents get mad it is they
don't take your advice but also just
don't tell them after you've done it
like if especially if you didn't take
their advice don't report back to them
unless they ask but that's the problem
is that she still wants to talk about it
because
okay but what I'm saying is stop doing
that whether you want to or not I know
seek the advice fine if they're happy to
give it fine but don't report back
unless you took their advice just tell
someone [__] else yeah there are
other people in the world besides your
parents if you know they're gonna get
all [__] butt hurt that you didn't
take their advice like they're 17 year
olds right right then don't tell them
just leave that part out of the whole
process problem solved done diddly done
I mean you're right you are right done
diddly done done okay the worst
therapist okay
all right cool yeah I mean that's just
so that hit me so oh it got me oh it got
me good got poked in the ass no you know
the [__] guy who who said the QVC guy
who's oh yeah
piece of that just got me bleeding dying
you know as he lays dying
as he lays die oh eat my unborn children
oh God
make sure if I die you eat my unborn oh
a piece of that just got me
bro this [__] has rips all right I'm
sweating oh I'm sweating I'm sweating
too focusing on that thank you so much
for your advice on how to live for
myself and authentically be myself it
was really helpful and really kind and I
really appreciate it so thank you
um I do have something else that I could
use some advice with
um go for runs every single day
um two and a half miles outside it was
like this great sense of release for me
my therapist said that like it was great
for me and I was like getting healthy
again and it was really great but
unfortunately I had to stop on one of my
runs I got hit by a car oh [__] so thank
goodness the only injury that I have is
that I sprained one of my ankles that's
it
um but no I can't run I can't even
really walk on it so I don't really get
that same sense of release that I used
to with running so I'm just curious what
other things that I could do that would
give me that sense of release
um for I I don't really like to go to
the gym I've had bad experiences and I
can't really like I said walk or run so
any advice would be helpful thank you
guys I appreciate it love you if you can
walk thank you sorry that how about
Jesus Christ thank God you [__] only
had a sprained ankle for getting hit by
a car that's like that's wild yeah it's
like how like Bruce Willis finds out
that he's [__] yeah yeah unbreakable
yeah yeah yeah
um yeah I mean low impact stuff
obviously what I would say is if you can
have any access to an exercise bike you
could you can actually have your ankle
locked right now connected and protected
and if you cycle
that's you don't need to do anything
else you can lock your ankle and then
just keep going yeah I mean if you could
walk she can walk is great yeah crutches
at the very least yeah rowing is
something you can do right that's a
great exercise although that sounds
harder to access it's a little easier
though rowing than [__] to me it's
it's easier than cycling and [__] but um
but cycling is like all you need to know
is where the [__] bike is rowing is
like you got to find a [__] body of
water you gotta no no no no you get a
[__] row machine
you get a Roma shoe the cat [__]
thinks I'm talking about go near Lake go
together go to Lake Castilla
so you mean
yeah I mean a [__] row machine that's
not nobody would understand what that is
but I'm doing the things okay cool yeah
so it's that a [__] cat running the
police academy guy so
um yeah I uh rowing uh cycling
um low impact stuff if you can walk then
you can step you know there's there's
um I think that you should start doing
you know just squats like body squats
and and as your [__] strengthens as your
[__] strengthens I mean you don't have
to put weight on it but I'm saying do a
million of them and then and as you put
weight on it your your ankle will get
strength uh more it'll get stronger and
then you can turn it into jumping a
little bit and but you know push-ups
there's tons of [__] you can do get a
[__] Bowflex you know Pilates is
great Pilates is great [__] yoga is
awesome you can do uh what's that one
with the um God I forget what it's
called it's like advanced
uh Pilates but it's a little bit more
aggressive I'll have to [__] think
about what it's called Bikram no okay I
think it's Bitcoin It's Hot Yoga oh yeah
uh uh I think find like a secondhand or
used rowing or cycling machine
and who cares if it's junky as [__]
you're just gonna have it until your
ankle heals
keep it outside if you have to and then
wait just do that until you're better
then sell it secondhand again for like
you know half of the price you bought it
for but it will have been a good
investment because you'll still get the
[__] benefits out of it what the [__]
is the thing called what are you talking
about uh I I used to do it no I used to
do it it was like a class I did it once
or twice and I can't remember what the
hell it was a martial arts no no no no
it was a like Advanced aggressive
Pilates it was like a machine involved
and like I can't remember what the hell
it's called whatever anyway do that okay
okay next one
the dog oh hi Max I love the podcast I
mean my boyfriend are big fans uh look
forward to the show and thank you for
Canada Chris when you finally book a
date
um my advice is is about aging and
birthdays so I have a 37th birthday
coming up which I'm dreading and feeling
a lot of anxiety about a lot probably
has to do with the fact that this year
we've been trying to start a family and
it hasn't happened yet so that's been
really hard on my mental health
so
um 37 just seems like a really big hit
uh so any type of advice on how to be
happy with it let me know make some
jokes anything I really really
appreciate it uh and thanks for all that
you do thanks cute look at the picture
in the back of both of them dude um I I
isn't it interesting it's always the
most beautiful people that are worried
about [__] aging actually that makes
sense because because they're hooked
into the [__] system of it they've
been beautiful their whole life and
they're worried about those looks fading
and let me get an ugly as [__]
[__] they don't care
but the the deal is it uh just that's so
that's good news so you don't have to
worry about the Aging in that respect I
know it's all about other stuff too
about starting a family and all that
[__] but um you're 37 you're not 55.
that's the thing dude 37 I can't even
tell you okay yeah in the last year just
the last year
I personally know
four maybe five but definitely four
people who have gotten pregnant and had
children after the age of 40. so yeah 37
is like just past
the automatic high risk thing like if
you're 35 and up you have to see a high
risk doctor but dude
you're just past that you're [__]
good you're good you weigh and you wanna
you wanna have kids and I don't know if
you've been trying or whatever uh she's
been trying she said she has been okay I
don't know how long but that's the other
thing if it's been a long time you have
even longer of a time to get pregnant go
easy on yourself The more stress you
have on about it the less likely you are
to [__] hit the jackpot it is funny
that nobody ugly is ever like I'm
worried about aging yeah because they
don't have to worry about that they
don't have to worry about that yeah
Robert De Niro I am turning to the end
of the day uh well it's always always
just like
yeah it's my 40th birthday but it's like
an athlete it's like an athlete being
like I'm losing my step I'm 37 now I'm
not as good as I was when I was 27 it's
like yeah but you're better than 99.9999
the [__] world but but what they're
saying yeah
yeah yeah oh no allergy but what they're
saying is still true
because they're the ones who feel it the
most beautiful people the loss of beauty
much more wow it's a poetic Beautiful
People you feel the feel of the loss of
people much much more the thing about me
is I speak I speak poetically okay and I
say [__] that people really remember
progress their lives because it's
impactful important and a big big deal
what changed people's lives all right I
changed people's hearts I change those
minds and I hug them okay see I've
changed it at the end so
uh yeah don't
I get it I get it I my
I think that in five ten years you're
gonna be looking back on this time and
you're gonna be like
I was worried about something that I
didn't have to be worried about yeah
dude and I and your the thing about
worrying is that it sucks because you're
worried what's gonna happen is gonna
happen anyway
you worrying about it isn't going to
change anything you're doing all you
need to do to try and get pregnant and
um or whatever it is live a happy life
um the fact that you're asking a
question you're in the right place
anyway but I would just you know the
fact that you're asking that question
means that you're somebody that
is a beautiful person so there you go
but that's the thing about worry and
anxiety it's there for a reason it's
like your weapon it's your tool and you
are utilizing that tool thus far how
you're supposed to use it you're doing
all the things that you're supposed to
be doing in terms of trying to get
pregnant you're worrying about your
future you're thinking about these
things don't let it pass the threshold
of useful to you anxiety and worry these
are actual skills that humans have
developed over many many years and let
that be your friend don't let it be your
enemy it's there to help you and it is
helping you don't let it go past the
Tipping Point yeah yeah make it start
hurting you have worrying is your friend
you're saying and and take it to dinner
maybe go to a movie with it right go see
that [__] like figurative Barbarian
movie I hear it's really good go to
Barbarian and get a popcorn get two
popcorns one for you and one for
worrying I want to see Barbarian
oh I want to see the movie Barbarian me
too learning English maybe I should go
with her anxiety yeah yeah you can go
you can go with her a seat in between
for the anxiety yeah she doesn't even
need to come she's busy whatever it
doesn't matter oh just kind of borrow
your anxiety
Barbarian yeah and I don't want to go
alone I want to see the movie Barbarian
stop saying it like
all right cool well we want to do one
more or something or what yeah
she is Matt Jonathan going out of Fresno
California
Chris I didn't missed the last time you
came here I don't know if you'll ever
come back but maybe not I had to work of
course the the
show and telling my boss won't let me
leave early
anyways I need some advice so me my wife
about our first baby should be popping
out any day now for sure hopefully soon
got a little girl on the way nice
um
question is
on the last my last name
for you know you fellow Italians Chris
and Matt last name is Vietti I really
want to have a little boy yeah I
obviously don't know what the future
holds but you know I'm thinking if I pop
three girls out that's matched for me I
don't know if if I want any movement
more out to that so just want to see
what you guys take on it keep going for
it until I pop out a boy
three's too many so some more peek out
yes it's kind of pushing it but you know
maybe four I mean talking I'm talking to
it let me know what you guys
you guys do love the Pod and watch every
week helps me get through my day
after work forget about it which is what
I'm doing now so nice let me know guys
thanks uh cool well that's a I think
about that sometimes stop thinking about
it oh the life the family line the the
[__] Vibe of the family still goes if
you have a [__] [__] girl she's just
telling you you're wrong uh it's it's I
think we're past the stage of worrying
about if the name continues they do in
the tutors they do that a lot they want
the name to continue what are you
[__] exactly yeah what are you Henry
the 350th the season 14 45 it's [__]
2022 we don't need to worry about our
names continuing it's not a thing yeah
but you know what
hey I get it you know what I mean Hey My
My hey I get it you know you want that
name to live on right well okay you want
to have a son of course but the name
gets to live on she can [__] combine
her name with whoever she finds a
partner with but broads can't carry the
name maybe she'll be gay and they keep
her last name like it sounded like a
[__]
Mario Andretti whatever the [__] his
name is you wanna [__] keep that name
going right why are you being a lot
louder when you do that because we're
Italian we're emotional you pop out a
[__] girl or two oh your namesake is
gone right right you want a [__] son
coming out of that [__]
what's that
hey so what are you here for you think
you're pregnant let's see spread them
[Laughter]
hey congratulations you're like four or
five weeks you're like two three weeks
in there
now well let's hope it's your boy so
your [__] husband's lineage could
live on right cause you know these
broads they don't carry the names hey
they don't carry nothing right you need
a piano getting upstairs who do you just
call anyway take two of these and call
me in the morning thanks a lot smoking
man I love my [__] job down the order
of a pizza pizza did I know I know a
couple who kept the female name
what and they named the child the female
they gave the child the female's last
name you just gotta be kidding me
[__] God
[Applause]
damn Tunas toadas the tutors the tutors
Henry the eight wow he started at Henry
then it was Henry II
then it was the you know
there was tree Henry's doesn't know the
story at all
how was her 300s if it's Henry VII
because you know any training and four
and five and six and you get to eight
and that one was the mother that
[__] was crazy it was all that
bad in his [__] broads you know they
were having [__] women and [__] yeah
yeah you got one kid he died of like
syphilis he got older okay said case
honestly okay
I wonder when you're gonna be done with
that what do you think once the lineage
[__] lives on
uh all right look we got our [__]
look how sick mentality shirts that's
the back that's the front we got [__]
hoodies we got everything dude we got
the crew neck yep
um I'll be in Peoria I'll be in Savannah
I'll be in Raleigh uh and I'll just be
doing all that [__] I got shows coming
up I'm in Tempe chrysalia.com uh and
that's what's up
mattelia.com get your [__] uh advice
sessions with me uh Tuesday or Thursday
1 30 to 5 30 Pacific time and I can't
wait to talk to you about whatever's on
your mind well the the lifeline live
show uh is your birthday show October
19th watch lifeline.com get your tickets
it's gonna be so [__] fun do it I
can't wait to [__] like annoy Matt
and do those jokes with you [__]
right and it's gonna be live a birthday
present from all of you to me
individually get your [__] ticket
meet me at my party on October 19th 6 PM
Pacific click on that in the comments
below watch lifeline.com uh and we'll
see you there dude thanks a lot
[Music]
hello